you must like you know the minute
version of who are you and then also
what is permanent equity yeah so urban
equity is we like specialist of family
of companies advise family-owned
companies so technically we're a private
equity firm now we were just a small
collection was my own capital and the
beginning of his entrepreneur and then
accidentally bought a business about ten
years ago and that's what led into kind
of what we do today but raised a
business yeah so I had a mutual
acquaintance saying hey you should meet
this guy he's in your industry and he
just got left at the altar for the
second time and I took that to mean I
should try to buy his business cuz why
else would tell me that he had no idea
he was just trying to connect to people
that were you know in the same in the
same field or similar fields and so I
don't know I look about 2425 now I
looked about 13 or 14 then and sat
across from the sky and told him I went
to buy his business and he laughed at me
and said to two grown men try to buy my
business how in the heck do you think
you're gonna do it and I said I'll
figure it out
we negotiated and he told me no thank
you
and then seven months later called me
back up and said alright let's move
forward and get it done so what would
your company before so I started kind of
collection of regional marketing
companies we started in 2007 I really
got going in 2008-9 which were as you
all know interesting times but it
actually allowed us to grow and we
adopted some video technology and it
becoming standard we think we were
probably the first people in the in the
world to use it for commercial purposes
but what does this mean what's regional
marketing you know we were doing look we
were doing like ad agency type of work
we're doing media buying we're doing
digital work you know trying to scrap
and claw and and sort of make a go of it
yeah so just innate you're you're an
agency just figuring it out yeah we had
some unusual talents kind of under that
agency because being in mid-missouri we
didn't have access to a lot of specialty
groups so we start building out our own
specialty groups so we've built our
research we did some mobile and app
development as well
and I'm in some film work so those were
kind of the three unusual buckets that
you typically don't get animation see
and how big give us a sense of the like
level of success I think a lot of people
one of the things we hear a lot is from
the audience's like but they hate when
we fast-forward and someone's like yeah
I did this thing and then all of a
sudden these amazing opportunities
opened up and they sort of her like wait
where were they before and so give us
the before picture how are you doing how
was that business doing financial do
they was it a big business small
business yeah yeah so we saw Lucy here
so I'm trying it's been a while since
I've thought about the numbers so we
grew to 26 employees I think at the peak
of that kind of before we were so we
were doing fine I can make a living
doing it I'm making good living doing it
it wasn't the agency business is hard
it's really really hard I think that's
probably what I've learned in my career
is I've made all the mistakes I've tried
and tested a lot of business models and
sort of taste and try something and
you're like up didn't realize how hard
that was gonna be any sort of you know
move around and so you know I would say
you know moderately successful regional
marketing firm nothing special I mean I
would say you know when yeah when we
bought the the firm that we did called
meaty cross you know we were kind of
co-equals is how I describe it kind of
in the marketplace they were much more
focused on government contracts that we
were reading any government contracts
that was really attractive about the
acquisition and being able to combine
those organizations gave us a lot more
cash flow than having them set for just
based on cross selling different
products that we had and being able to
fulfill a lot more of the a lot more of
the gross profit through sort of a
larger organization that they had been
farming out some stuff so that was I was
kind of a nice combination so did you
buy that first company under the
umbrella of your of your marketing
business yeah yeah correct
got it and so it wasn't its own entity
no well I mean it wasn't me technically
it was his own density but it was a
hundred percent owned by me and a
hundred percent the other firm is owned
by me so I mean it's sure responded well
you didn't have a girl found her or any
outside investors or anything yeah so I
bought it with an SBA loan
thank God for the SBA and so no it was
it was just a it was SBA loan and rolled
the dice
[Music]